So Donald Trump was interviewed on 60 minutes last night
we showed a piece of that interview in our story about Saudi Arabia and the death of
Journalist Jamal khashoggi, but I want to talk in general about this interview
60 minutes is a program that's been around for 50 years. They've done everything
interviews with presidents coverage of war zones
celebrity stories
investigative takedowns of scams of all sorts
Coverage of political campaigns and we don't have to like every story that 60 minutes is done
We don't have to like every journalist or correspondent who works on 60 minutes
But one of the things on 60 minutes is that we expect the program will be taken seriously by the guests
And I don't mean we respect and bow at every question that's asked by Scott Pelley or Lesley
Stahl or whoever we still apply the same criticisms to 60 minutes the minutes that we do to any media program
But we expect the interviewee to take it seriously and at least respect that 60 minutes does their homework
They take story seriously. They put resources behind what they do
gets us to last night Donald Trump sat down with Lesley, Stahl and
made a mockery not only of the office of the presidency by lying and distorting and avoiding but made a mockery of the
institution of journalism
Which he probably relishes doing actually and as a result he continues to prove that there is this
downfall of basic decorum and decency in the United States
Which truly makes us look like morons around the world and I want to look at some of the key moments with you
Donald Trump claimed that he got Brett Kavanaugh confirmed by making fun of
Sexual assault victim Christine Blasi Ford and that it doesn't matter what happened
Because it worked and got Kavanagh on the court take a look at this you go out and you go to Mississippi the famous
Mississippi speech I had one beer
Well, you think it was it. Nope. That was one beer. Oh good. How did you get home? I don't remember
How'd you get there? I don't remember. Where is the place? I don't remember how many years ago was?
And you mimicked
Professor Blasi Ford you mimicked her had I not made that speech we would not have won
I was just saying she didn't seem to know anything and you're trying to destroy a life of a man
Who has been extraordinary? Why did you have to make fun of her? I didn't really make fun
They were like I said is the person that we're talking about didn't know the Year at the time the place
Professor Blasi Ford got before the Senate and and was asked what's the worst moment?
She said when the two boys laughed at me at my expense
And then I watched you mimic her and thousands of people were laughing at her
They can do what they tell you the way
Now justice Cavanaugh was traded
Has become a big factor in the midterms. Have you seen what's gone on with the polls?
But did you have to well, I think she was treated with great respect. I'll be honest
What do you think there were those are things you shouldn't do you think you treated her with great? I think so
Yeah
I did but you seem to be saying that she lied
What you know what I'm not gonna get into it because we won it doesn't matter consider the circular reasoning
He made fun of her because otherwise they would have lost
But he's not going to talk about making fun of her because they won which he says is
Because he made fun of her
This is the type of logic you expect your ignorant uncle at Thanksgiving to use not the President of the United States on 60 minutes
Here was a really strange moment to Lesley stalls credit. She didn't throw all softballs at Trump
Only some softballs one softball was what's the biggest surprise?
from being president and what have you learned as being president total softball question Trump seems
unable to
seriously reflect on the world and he concoct some story about what he was shocked by is how dishonest the media is and
How he's just done the best out of anybody who's been president
What's the biggest surprise?
And what have you learned?
Since you've been president, okay, so I always used to say the toughest people of Manhattan seit guys and Baba
Now I say they're babies who they benefits the political people. This is the most deceptive
Vicious world it is vicious
It's full of lies deceit and deception you make a deal with somebody and it's like making a deal with that table
Give me an example. Well, I don't want to give you an example. I'm not looking in the meantime
Nobody's been able to do what I've been able to do right remember that when you look at taxes you look at
regulations you look at
making deals with other countries
Nobody's been able to do anything like this
Actually, most people didn't even try because they knew they didn't have the ability to do it
But it's a very deceptive world. The other thing I've really learned is I never knew how dishonest the media was
So it's a softball what's been the biggest surprise what's been difficult?
His answer is I was surprised at how I've been able to do things
No other president has been able to do as effectively already sang by saying he's done things
Nobody else has done and he was surprised by how dishonest the media was then we get into Russia
Okay, and two leslee stalls credit, this was not a softball. She really tried on Russia
So this one we want to pay close attention to let's see how it starts on Russia. Okay
People don't understand why you never have a harsh word for Vladimir Putin. Okay. You're right. I don't understand
I have been you don't know what I talked about with Putin in the meeting prior to the president publicly
You never say anything harsh gives me I didn't I'm the one that gave
Ukraine
Offensive weapons and tank killers Obama didn't you know what he sent he sent pillows and blankets
I'm the one and he's the one that gave away a part of Ukraine
Where Russia now has this separation him personally
Vladimir I think I'm very tough with him personally. I had a meeting with him the two of us. Yeah
It was a very tough meeting and it was a very good meeting. So it's important to notice here that he said nothing
He said well first he answered about giving Ukraine stuff and then when Lesley Stahl presses him
He says we had a tough meeting and we had a strong meeting
Let's continue because now we get into election interference and here it gets really interesting pay attention closely to what Trump says
Do you agree that Vladimir Putin is involved in assassinations in?
Poisonings probably he is. Yeah, probably. I mean, I don't have I believe probably but I rely on them
It's not in our code. Okay, why why not? They shouldn't do it. This is a terrible thing course you shouldn't do it
Give it to you you believe that the Russians interfered in the 2016 campaign
Election. Well, they meddle but I think China metal - they did
metal and so did China
Minimize and distract it was meddling not interference and it's the exact same thing that China did
Well, that's not what our intelligence agencies are saying
And as this part of the interview continues, you'll notice him do the same thing over and over which is interrupt the full question
So the viewer doesn't even hear the full question and then introduce some kind of unrelated information
And then conflate it with the actual issue, I think
Why don't you rush in mental because I think China meddled also and I think frankly China
This is a bigger problem. You're diverting the whole Russian thing doing anything
I'm saying Russia, but I'm also saying China. This is how it works sort of deny
Sort of say yes deflect conflate confuse
And then if you need to you attack the interviewer
And then this is where it really becomes embarrassing Trump said during like an oh what's called?
I think they're over not over time 60 minutes extra or something like that that the Federal Reserve
Thinks that our economy is too good
Did you know that the economy is too strong right now and the Federal Reserve needs to make it not as strong
People are saying one of the reasons the stock market plunged this week because of the China tariffs
Its peanuts the reason his interest rates have gone up because our Federal Reserve
Is raising rates too fast because they think our economy is too good
And I say I don't want you to every time we announce a good quarter you have to raise interest rates
I don't want that. I'm very unhappy with the Federal Reserve. Yeah, but they're independent your honor independent
So they do what they are poor a man, and I'm so far disappointed maybe some day
I think he's the greatest but right now I'm very your hands a time, right? Yeah. It's an independent agency
I appoint him and I you know, I capita like low interest rates. You want to know the truth
He sees their economy as being so strong. So powerful that he keeps raising interest rates. I don't that's right
The economy is too good
And then now let's go to layer two of this which is all right Lesley Stahl did an okay job?
Here Trump's the embarrassment, but if you look at the comments on these videos from the interview on YouTube
This is the type of thing you see from trumpets and this
Explains why Trump has a nearly 40 percent approval rating and could win re-election
choice comments
Stall is that short for Stalin sounds like this interviewer tries to catch President Trump?
But the president wins he's defying her evil questions if that's your view
You reelect Trump another comment from YouTube about this interview. I don't believe in violence
But this is why women are not believed listen to this woman. What a disgrace to quote
journalism and
Yet another example and there are many of these this dumb blonde kept trying to trick him guilt him trap him
Didn't work
This is why you've got a vote in three weeks and why you must vote in
2020 the world is laughing and nearly 40% of the country says I approve of this man
I approve of the job that he is doing we're in real trouble if we don't all get out there and vote
Quick break back after this one of today's sponsors is Skillshare
Which is an amazing online learning community that offers thousands of high quality classes on almost any topic
first 500 people who click the link under this video will get two entire months of
totally free access to every single class offered by Skillshare
they've got classes on everything from design video editing photography business technology cooking meditation even
classes on personal productivity
I know you'll be able to find something on Skillshare that fascinates you or even something that will help you in your everyday life
Classes are taught by real people who care about what they're teaching
I just took a really great class on more advanced video editing
techniques
The david pakman show is giving you two months of free access to every class they offer when you click the link under this video
Think about everything you'll have at your fingertips for two whole months
totally free hard to beat and after that if you like it you can keep
Access to every class on Skillshare for under ten bucks a month one of the most affordable
Learning platforms out there. Just click the link under this video to redeem your to three months of Skillshare, but hurry
It's only available to the first 500 who sign up